du hast dich eben du bist nicht nur
schauspieler hast bücher geschrieben
engagiert sich umweltpolitisch überhaupt
politisch und da vor allem ganz aktuell
beim generationen manifest
was ist das denn so ein bisschen die
idee die politik mal ganz kurz
aufzuwecken
weil die einen ja nun seit jahren so vor
sich hin zwischen euro-rettung und
unfassbaren geschwätz und es folgen
irgendwie dann doch erschreckend wenig
taten
und ganz ehrlich ob die generation die
am gelackmeierten ist von allem sind die
jetzt so manchen jugendlichen die sich
vom fernseh gucken weil es ging
verabschiedet haben das heißt der ganzen
wahlkampf läuft über medien der
eigentlich an jugendlichen und jungen
leuten total vorbei gibt die lese keine
zeitung also klassisch die welt blätter
und die genfer see und da tut man sich
ständig diese politiker medientross und
sagen anders alles großartig bewegen sie
liegen ja ganz erschreckend wenig und
ich denke wenn es wirklich in zukunft
geht müssen eine politik machen die die
jugendlichen einbezieht und b natürlich
auch die jugendlichen dazu animieren
sich politischen irgendeiner form zu
melden und aktiv zu werden
was sind die wichtigsten punkte also ich
denke immer umwelt und bildung die
bildungspolitik läuft es nach wie vor so
dass dann der demeter kind bist du
selber studieren gehen wenn du kein
akademiker ist dass sie nicht studieren
gehen also die durchlässigkeit des
bildungssystems in 15 jahren stecken
geblieben und tragisch nur hat man den
eindruck wir haben ein wahnsinnig
festgefahrenes parteiensystem ist bewegt
sich eben nichts wir haben dieses jahr
fast komplett wahlprogramme man hat den
eindruck da ist nichts mehr drin und das
ist ja auch ein problem deswegen
interessieren sich nur wenig aus der
jungen generation von politik weil man
den bewegt sich nichts er ist gut ist
eine problematische angela merkel
grundsätzlich die guten wahlprogramme
der parteien hat cloud und das auch
offen zugibt sie sagt also die idee mit
der mietpreisbindung dies offen der spd
aber ich mache das jetzt auch ich glaube
die einzig noch ein bisschen profi haben
und natürlich auch etwas jünger und wir
sind die grünen die manege ganz
pragmatisch sagen wir brauchen ein
plastiktüten verboten
da sage ich schon mal da wo endlich
kommen auf die jemand auf die idee
irgendwas gegen plastik zu tun
und natürlich sind es diejenigen die
alternativen energie der meisten fördern
werden und dafür sorgen werden dass wir
irgendwie aus fossilen brennstoffen
sprich öl gas an dem ganzen atom treck
man doch auskommen also ich persönlich
glaube das ganze ist ziemlich wild
grün-weiß meines arztes jüngste
parteiprogramm ist aber wie kann man
denn überhaupt wo kann man denn dann
dran der partei fest machen wenn die
wahlprogramme alle so ähnlich sind
also erstens finde ich gibt es an diesen
unterschiedlichen sich auf kommunaler
ebene politisch engagieren und auf
bundesebene
auf bundesebene wird man wahnsinnig
schnell verschließen genauso wie die
politiker bildungs ständig beschweren
ich glaube es gibt auch gar keine
politikverdrossenheit es gibt eine
politik für hausmeister für politik
interessieren sich ganz viele schulen an
nur wenn du dann halt die epigonen sie
ist unsere parteien unsere regierung
verliert mal ganz schnell die lust und
ich glaube dass also ich persönlich
engagiere mich warten nur auf der
kommunalen ebene weil da kannst du auch
am meisten wählen das kann auch wirklich
jeder 20-jährige jeder 25 auf kommunaler
ebene echte angeschrieben da gibt auch
etwas zu bewegen als ich werde mich von
einem kleinen dorf ging es vor einigen
jahren zwischen davon ob man da ein lidl
supermarkt hin bauen lässt oder nicht
und daran wollen wir nicht wir wollen so
kleinen geschäfte behalten und diese die
kultur dort schützen
das ist entscheidend für sein das kann
ich nachvollziehen da ist einfach das
gefühl da hast du deine hand und das
hatten direkten effekt auf bundesebene
meine sachen verpufft das sondern
irgendwo zwischen lobbyismus und
parteigremien und nicht wie es nicht
wohl aber dein tipp ist oder sein deine
erfahrung ist schon wenn ich
lokalpolitisch mitmacher kann ich
wirklich was bewegen da muss nicht alles
seinen gang gehen sondern ich kann
bestimmen mitbestimmen
der lidl kommt da zum beispiel nicht hin
also das ist auf der kommunalen ebene
zwei stellen thema man muss sich auch
man muss habe ich eine partei eintreten
erst zu engagieren es gibt ja einzellige
nichtregierungsorganisation
und initiativen mitmachen kann er ich
glaube dass ein zimmer recht verboten
ist meckern und dann nichts tun also
wenn merck hat muss sich auch engagieren
weil wir nichts tut hat auch kein recht
zu wecken